Saudi Arabia's official explanation of
the death of Washington Post contributor
Jamal Khashoggi has failed to end
allegations of a cover-up Saudi
officials say King Salman and the Crown
Prince have called Khashoggi son to
offer condolences president Trump spoke
with Turkey's president on the phone
yesterday and agreed the case needs to
be cleared up major garrett is at the
White House major good morning good
morning president Trump appears willing
to believe the Saudis that Khashoggi
--zz death they say was not murder that
the crown prince de facto leader of the
kingdom knew nothing about it and that
the Saudis can be trusted to conduct a
credible investigation even though
they've had to admit under intense
international pressure that this death
Khashoggi scam at their hands well key
US allies in Europe and key voices in
Congress say the Saudis story doesn't
add up
I do I mean it's again it's early
President Trump said he believed Saudi
Arabia's evolving story that Washington
Post columnist and US resident Jamal
khashoggi died after a fight broke out
inside the Saudi consulate in Istanbul
we haven't finished our review or
investigation I think it's a very
important first step and after nearly
three weeks the Saudis have not said
where Khashoggi --zz body is nobody
seems to know somebody knows mr. Trump
also said no US intelligence agency has
heard an audio recording or read a
transcript reportedly of khashoggi
violent death we've heard about it but
nobody's seen it Saudi Arabia's foreign
minister said khashoggi died at the
hands of Saudi security personnel many
with ties to Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman who acted on their own providing
no evidence supporting the claims this
is a mistake this is a criminal act and
those responsible before it will be
punished the conference has denied the
circumference is not aware of this top
lawmakers were not buying it and looked
to the crown prince known widely as MBS
it's my thinking that MBS was involved
in this that he directed this and that
this person was purposely murdered while
the White House waits pressure builds to
confront the Saudis I cannot do business
with the current leadership for his part
the president praised the crown prince's
quote very good control of the kingdom
but acknowledged there's been lies with
the Saudis shifting explanations
Treasury secretary Steve manoosh in who
announced he was canceling an appearance
at a Saudi sponsored investment
conference later this month will
nevertheless stop in the kingdom to
discuss counterterrorism issues with the
kingdom's leadership meanwhile the
president of Turkey said John Tuesday he
will announce an update in Turkey's part
of this Khashoggi investigation major
the president promised very severe
consequences what's what exactly is the
White House considering well a key
working relationship with Congress is
beginning to emerge and the president's
talking about that with a bit more
specificity there's an underlying law
that requires sanctions to those
responsible for carrying out a human
rights violation of this kind but
there's no sense here John the
president's going to tamper with an
existing arms deal with the Saudis or
fundamentally alter the heighth u.s.
relationship with the kingdom and made
you the president's son-in-law Jared
Kushner has a tight relationship with
the Crown Prince how does that affect
this calculus well that relationship was
forged during the transition John when
MBS the Crown Prince reached out to
Jared Kushner president elect Trump
empowered Kushner to develop a close
working relationship with the Saudis as
a counterweight to Iran the United
States and the Saudis have been very
close on arms deals Yemen other issues
in the region and Jared Kushner has
relied heavily on the Crown Prince to
forward that trump agenda in the region
and now has to explain if that close
relationship in some way gave the Saudis
a sense that they could go much farther
than the u.s. or this administration is
comfortable with and the khashoggi
matter all right major thank you so much